[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Ellen enie hallo und herzlich willkommen
zum Presseclub an diesem Sonntag sie
haben es gerade in der Tagesschau
gesehen der neue Verteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius will so schnell wie
möglich in die Ukraine reisen dort tobt
der russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
und Ukraine er geht mit unverminderter
Härte weiter jeden Tag sterben Menschen
auf beiden Seiten und gleichzeitig
wächst der Druck auf Deutschland in der
panzerfrage sollte Deutschland auch
schwere Kampfpanzer wie den Leopard
liefern an die Ukraine oder das
zumindest anderen Ländern gestatten
darüber wird seit Wochen heftig
diskutiert und besonders intensiv am
vergangenen Freitag in Ramstein bei der
sogenannten Ukraine Kontaktgruppe
[Musik]
komm im Amt steht Boris Pistorius als
Verteidigungsminister schon voll im fok
nicht nur die Ukraine auch Nato-Partner
EU-Staaten und sogar die eigenen
Koalitionspartner fordern von
SPD-Kanzler Olaf Scholz die Ukraine im
Krieg gegen Russland stärker zu
unterstützen ganz konkret geht es um den
deutschen Panzer Leopard im Klartext
kannst du Leoparden liefern oder nicht
dann gib sie her es ist ja nicht so dass
wir angreifen falls ich da jemand Sorgen
macht doch Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
geht Entdeckung er will Alleingänge
unbedingt vermeiden den Vorwurf
Deutschland Bremse die Entscheidung
weist sein neuer Verteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius deutlich zurück es gibt
gute Gründe für die Lieferung des gute
Gründe dagegen
und angesichts der Gesamtsituation eines
Krieges der jetzt schon fast ein Jahr
dauert sind alle Pro und Contras sehr
sorgfältig abzuwägen
Panzer liefern ja oder nein und vor
allem wann die Lage hat sich für die
Ukraine deutlich verschlechtert Russland
mobilisiert massiv ein Abwägen das für
die Ukraine angesichts dieser Bilder
kaum auszuhalten ist
das ist unser Thema heute im Presseclub
Pistorius und die panzerfrage warum
zögert die Bundesregierung und ich freue
mich über diese Gäste herzlich
willkommen Erik bonsel er ist freier
Journalist und eu-korrespondent der taz
die Tageszeitung ich begrüße ganz
herzlich Nana Brink sie ist freie
Journalistin und stellvertretende
Vorsitzende von wise.de einem Netzwerk
für Frauen in der Sicherheitspolitik
herzlich willkommen auch Stefan
Cornelius Politik Ressortleiter bei der
Süddeutschen Zeitung und ich begrüße
herzlich Paul ronsheimer in der Runde
stellvertretender Chefredakteur und
kriegskrisenreporter bei der Bild ja
schon jetzt wird heftig diskutiert in
den sozialen Medien auch Sie können sich
an dieser Debatte beteiligen auf den
Plattformen wo der Presseclub der
streamt wird ich möchte mit einer Frage
an Herrn ronsheimer beginnen sie waren
ja glaube ich zuletzt im Dezember in der
Ukraine vor Ort sie waren auch zu Beginn
des Krieges dort sehr präsent sind
bestens vernetzt was können Sie uns über
die aktuelle Situation zum Beispiel rund
um bachmut sagen wo ja jetzt so heftig
gekämpft wird ja die Lage in bachmut ist
dramatisch bei Russland eben
zehntausende Menschen dort rein schickt
durch die Mobilisierung also die reine
Masse an Menschen Solidar also der Ort
in der Nähe von bachmut ist komplett
zerstört auch bachmutig weil er selbst
im Frühherbst noch Kämpfe
also man muss eines klar sagen diese
Optimismus den auch die Ukraine
versprüht haben und um Herbst als es die
Rückeroberung gibt der verfliegt so
langsam und das liegt einerseits an den
Mobilisierung und andererseits eben
daran dass die Ukraine wirklich
verzweifeln wenn man die Worte von Boris
pustorius hört man müsste jetzt prüfen
und es gebe beide Argumente da höre ich
aus der Ukraine wie kann das sein dieser
Krieg ist jetzt ein Jahr alt und immer
noch wollen die Deutschen uns erzählen
dass sie irgendwo Panzer prüfen wir
müssen suchen müssen und immer wieder
neue Ausreden finden man ist das kann
man sagen rund um silensky einfach
unfassbar wütend auf diese
Bundesregierung sie beziehen sich jetzt
auf den O-Ton den wir auch gerade im
Einspieler gehört haben es gibt
Argumente für und gegen eine
panzerlieferung sie haben gerade gesagt
der Optimismus verpufft jetzt so ein
bisschen was ist denn ihre Einschätzung
wie lange wird die Ukraine diesen
massenhaften angriffsseitens Russland
standhalten können also wir sehen ja
Putin scheut nicht einen abnutzungskrieg
mannomann Meter und Meter wie lange
glauben sie kann die Ukraine das
Durchhalten die Ukraine wird es nicht
durchhalten können wenn es nicht weitere
Waffen gibt das ist aus meiner Sicht
ganz klar man kann durchhalten in der
Zeit also wir sehen ja das auch wenn die
Russen angreifen ist sehr sehr lange
dauert bis einzelne Orte und Städte
tatsächlich erobert werden aber die Zeit
spielt für Putin das ist aus meiner
Sicht ganz klar wenn es nicht weitere
Lieferung für die Ukraine gibt man hat
nicht genügend Material nennt man darf
eine Sache nicht vergessen das ist das
wenn ich dort mit meinen Kontakten
spreche man hat große Sorgen dass es
einen erneuten Angriff Richtung Westen
geben könnte also aus Belarus Richtung
Kiew möglicherweise also das ist ein
drei frontenkrieg entsteht und dann
stünden wir wieder dort wo wir im
Februar im März standen nämlich vor der
Frage was passiert wenn tatsächlich Kiew
wieder angegriffen werden dann gucken
wir vielleicht mal ganz konkret darum
ging es ja unter anderem auch am Freitag
in Ramstein bei dem Treffen der Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe auch das haben wir eben in
der Tagesschau gehört dabei wurde von
Boris Pistorius dem neuen
Verteidigungsminister angekündigt wir
würden jetzt mal überprüfen lassen
welche und wie viele Leopard Panzer
überhaupt in Frage geben für eine
Lieferung an die Ukraine in den
Bundeswehrbeständen muss das jetzt
geprüft werden Herr Cornelius da auch
darüber gibt es jetzt schon
Kopfschütteln also wie kann es sein dass
wir am Freitag angefangen haben das zu
prüfen vielleicht ist das gar nicht so
was meinen Sie ist auch nicht so diese
panzerliste ist natürlich
vorhanden wir haben schon vor Monaten
über diese Panzer diskutiert damals
wurden auch schon Listen erstellt
genauer Erhebungen angestellt dass diese
200 Leopard 2
ab Panzer die im deutschen Arsenal sind
unterschiedliche Baureihen in welchem
Zustand die sich befinden wo sie genau
disloziert sind was man damit machen
kann und die Frage des deutschen
Beitrags ist ja noch mal völlig
losgelöste Betrachten von der
eigentlichen Frage die die Verbündeten
noch viel stärker umtreibt nämlich die
Ausfuhr Genehmigung die Bundesregierung
für diese Leopard der auch erteilen muss
an alle Staaten die Sie jemals gekauft
haben sind Polen die finden wir auch
immer bereit ist diese Panzer zu liefern
und in beiden Punkten also Ausführung
und das eigene Arsenal ist die
Bundesregierung sehr defensiv ist sie
eigentlich nicht transparent und ähm
wenn ich das sogar noch konkretisieren
darf ist der Kanzler nicht transparent
denn der Rest der Bundesregierung ist
nach meiner Analyse sehr sehr festgelegt
auch historius hat bereits Andeutungen
gemacht dass er ich meine allein dass er
sagt wir prüfen das wieder und nicht
definitiv absagt ist ja ein Zeichen
dafür dass er auch diese Option noch
offenhält also es gibt auch innerhalb
der Bundesregierung deutliche Konflikte
wir sehen dass es die Koalition jetzt
erreicht das heißt die Grünen und die
FDP haben sich eindeutig positioniert
zugunsten der Lieferung das ist also
eine Sache die da Kanzler zu begründen
hat und er tut's nicht vielleicht ganz
konkret noch die Frage an Sie da gab es
ja die Diskussion um ein jungtim also
von wegen Deutschland liefert nur wenn
Amerika auch seine kampfwasser
Kampfpanzer Abrams liefern würde das
hatte unter anderem die Süddeutsche
Zeitung berichtet und dann hieß es nein
nein ein solches Jugendamt gibt's nicht
was ist denn da jetzt der aktuelle Stand
der Familie ist der Bundeskanzler hatte
amerikanischen Präsident gesagt ich
mache das nur wenn du die ARD Bremse
liefert und nachdem das öffentlich wurde
und man eigentlich den amerikanischen
Präsidenten nicht öffent nicht unter
Druck setzt
gab es natürlich ein Gegendruck aus
Washington und am Donnerstag kam es zu
einer zu einem sehr hässlichen Telefonat
das amerikanischen Sicherheitsberaters
mit seinem deutschen gegenüber das ist
der außenpolitische Berater des Kanzlers
in dem es sehr sehr deutliche Worte gab
und am selben Tag war ja der
amerikanische Verteidigungsminister
Austin im Kanzleramt auch bei historius
aber das eigentliche zentrale Gespräch
war im Kanzleramt und auch dort hat es
gerumst also die USA mögen ist nicht
wenn man ihnen öffentlich Bedingungen
stellt genauso wenig wie das Deutschland
macht das macht man nicht unter
Verbündeten und am Freitag wurde das
dann dementiert vom von der
Bundesregierung vom Regierungssprecher
aber ich ähm denke dass der ganze
Vorgang zeigt wie viel Feuer darunter
ist das heißt also auch das Verhältnis
der Deutschen zu den USA im Moment etwas
katastrophal also die Amerikaner sind
ernsthaft sauer und das kann man seine
Mutter dass sie sauer sein aber ich
glaube man muss schon überlegen wo man
im Moment sein ein politisches Kapital
verspielt und die Isolation Deutschlands
ist im Moment sehr stark
Frau Brink vielleicht in Verbindung mit
ein paar Einlassungen auf Twitter
einerseits Stefan Schröder fragt ist
Deutschland überhaupt noch ein
verlässlicher Nato-Partner andererseits
Jahn auf Twitter wer meint ernsthaft mit
Panzern ließe sich ein Krieg gegen eine
atommachtgewinn das sind ja so ein
bisschen die zwei Pole der Debatte wie
schätzen Sie das ein aus
sicherheitspolitischer Sicht naja also
mit einem Leopard Panzer oder auch einer
meinetwegen einer Kompanie was 14 Stück
sind wird man irgendwie den Krieg nicht
drehen das ist aber eigentlich nicht nur
unter Experten sondern eigentlich auch
in der Politik Gang und game also man
muss sich immer vorstellen was kann der
Leopard das ist ja immer so dieses
Gerücht umgegangen das ist ein
Kampfpanzer ein Angriff Panzer und das
ist auch glaube ich das was Scholz er
kann schon ein bisschen angedeutet
vielleicht umtreibt ja dass er irgendwie
das Bild hat dass ein deutscher
Kampfpanzer dann auf russischem
Territorium gibt das ist natürlich
Unsinn sondern es macht nur Sinn wenn
man diese Waffen im Verbund benutzt und
das ist ja auch das Gefecht der
verbundenen Waffen das wird in jeder
Bundeswehr Experte bestätigen und es hat
die Bundesregierung und das ist deshalb
auch so fatal das verbunden mit mit
anderen Beispiel mit dem Marder mit dem
Geparden mit der Panzerhaubitze und erst
dann macht es wirklich Sinn und das ist
eigentlich so bedauerlich dass die
Bundesregierung das auch nicht
eigentlich in der Kommunikation nach
außen getragen hat weil die
Bundesregierung oder der Bundesrepublik
hat ja bereits geliefert es war
sukzessive aber es ist ja immer ein
Schritt nach dem anderen passiert es
sind die Mörder gekommen es sind die
Haubitzen gekommen das ist der Gepard
gekommen jetzt kommt der Leopard
sozusagen als das letzte Mittel man muss
ja auch eskalationsmöglichkeiten haben
ja und deshalb ist es so um so
unverständlicher dass eigentlich da
nicht reagiert wird auch übrigens nicht
im Bündnis und das ist ja das zweite
Argument was ich auch wirklich sehr
verteilt finde weil immer vom Alleingang
die Rede ist ja und der einzige
Alleingang der eigentlich passiert ist
in deutscher Alleingang also wir haben
seit Wochen einen polnischen Vorschlag
wir haben den Vorschlag der Finn die
zwar noch nicht NATO-Mitglied sind aber
es ja hoffentlich bald werden das heißt
es kann gar kein Rede sein von
Alleingang und es wäre eigentlich und
das finde ich sehr fatal die Aufgabe
eigentlich von Deutschland gewesen und
das ist auch der Grund weshalb ich
glaube dass die Amerikaner so sauer sind
ja weil sie gesagt haben was wollt ihr
denn abrames haben ihr habt den Leopard
wir müssen den nicht transportieren
sondern ihr könnt eigentlich ins Lied
gehen ihr müsst das eigentlich auf
europäischer Ebene lösen und das wäre
eigentlich die Aufgabe von von
Deutschland gewesen sie haben jetzt
gerade von einer Scheibchen Taktik oder
Salami Taktik gesprochen Herr bonse
haben Sie denn Verständnis dafür dass
der Kanzler jetzt also ihm wird ja oft
zögern vorgeworfen er sagt aber
andererseits das ist eine schwerwiegende
Entscheidung das ist eine sehr brenzlige
Situation man muss sich gut überlegen
welche Schritte man wann macht haben sie
da Verständnis für absolut natürlich
also das ganze ist ja nur macht ja nur
Sinn im Teil einer
konsentierten Strategie also wir können
nicht über einzelne Waffensysteme reden
sondern wir müssen über die Strategie
reden wir müssen darüber sprechen geht
es um den Sieg der Ukraine wie der
schwedische EU-Vorsitz jetzt sagt wenn
ja was bedeutet siegte Ukraine heißt das
dass wir bis nach Moskau marschieren
oder heißt es dass wir die Krümme
erobern wie es jetzt in den USA zum
Beispiel erwogen wird oder bedeutet ist
dass wir auf die Linie vom 24 Februar
letzten Jahres zurückgehen das ist
völlig offen aber es macht mich auch
deswegen
sprachlos die gesamte Debatte weil ich
das aus Brüsseler Sicht wo ich ja Arbeit
als EU natuskurs benennt überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen kann dort hören sie kein
Wort der Kritik an Deutschland kein Wort
der Kritik außer aus dem Europaparlament
wo Reinhard bütighofer einen grünen
Politiker sozusagen eine große Koalition
mit CDU bisschen den konservativen ein
bisschen nach Polen gegründet hat um
dann auch innenpolitisch natürlich Druck
zu machen
wenn Sie den Nato-Generalsekretär Fragen
er lobt ist voll des Lobes für
Deutschland weil er erst vor zwei Wochen
Panzer Zuge worden sind sie hatten es
erwähnt die Marder das ist ja erst zwei
Wochen her und wir tun so als hätte
Deutschland gar nichts geliefert jetzt
wurde Patrick System zugesagt im
November wurde Iris t zugesagt und zwar
schneller als die USA Deutschland war
nicht hinter der Welle wir gerne gesagt
wird im November sondern bei der
Luftabwehr war es vor der Welle und ich
habe von den Eindruck aus Brüssel dass
das eigentlich eine Kampagne ist die vor
allem von Polen gefahren wird in Polen
ist Wahlkampf die piss versucht mit
deutschfeindlichen Tönen da Kampagne zu
machen und am Ende des Tages und das
macht mich wirklich besorgt sieht es
doch so aus als sollte Deutschland zum
dünndenburg gestempelt werden das heißt
wenn es schief geht die lesen sie ja
überall nicht nur auf Twitter auch an
einigen deutschen Zeitung schon ist
Deutschland schuld weil es ein
bestimmtes Waffen Modell nicht liefern
hat und das ist aus meiner Sicht völlig
absurd das geht in den Tatsachen wenn
ich da kurz eingreifen darf er gesagt
dann aus europäischer Sicht also wir
haben ja die Diskussionen
Europaparlament gehabt in Straßburg wo
ja Scholz öffentlich vorgeführt worden
ist also ich kann jetzt nicht
feststellen dass es auf Europaebene
keine Kritik an Deutschland gibt ja und
ich kann auch nicht feststellen wenn wir
uns den Talent page angucken also es ist
erst ich weiß genau am Donnerstag vor
Rammstein haben sich neun NATO-Staaten
verabredet und haben gesagt wir wollen
dringend schwere Waffen nicht nur
schwere Waffen da gebe ich Ihnen recht
ja es ist nicht der Leopard entscheidend
aber wir haben uns dazu zusammengefunden
das zu tun und das war ohne Deutschland
ja also ich kann nicht sehen das ist
keine ganz kurz das Europa-Parlament da
haben sie völlig recht das war aber in
der Tat können Sie auch über nachlesen
unter Anleitungen sozusagen der Grünen
der deutschen Grünen im Europaparlament
das muss man aber wissen hat aus dem
politisch gar nichts zu melden also es
macht jede Menge Resolution zu Russland
immer auf der harten Linie hat aber wird
überhaupt nicht an den
Abstimmungsprozessen im Rat beteiligt
werden
da gibt's keine Widerstand
sehr problematisch denn sie gerade
genannt haben Frage gestellt was will
die Ukraine und sie tun so als würde es
in der Ukraine Stimmen geben man wolle
bis Moskau marschieren das finde ich
sehr sehr schwierig denn das ist ja auch
das was glaube ich den deutschen Angst
macht und wenn man sich einmal anschaut
wie ist die Ukraine bislang mit den
Waffensystemen umgegangen die sie
bekommen hat keiner in der Ukraine will
bis Moskau dieses Land verteidigt sich
in diesem Land sterben jeden Tag
Menschen dieses Land wird von Russland
angegriffen und wenn man dann in der
Debatte so tut als würden jetzt deutsche
Panzer dazu benutzt Russland anzugreifen
dann ist das einfach Quatsch und das
sollten wir auch nicht ja auch machen
ich habe nicht gesagt dass die Ukraine
bis Moskau marschieren will das war die
offene Frage was ist das Ziel der Kamera
gut aber sie ist das ja wenn oder wollen
die Wissen gesagt aber sie wissen ja
sicherlich auch oder wahrscheinlich
besser als ich das ist doch schon einige
Vorfälle gegeben hat also der Angriff
auf die kehrbrücke ach das ist jetzt
auch russisches Gebiet für Sie oder oder
geht es um die Brücke die das russische
Festland mit der Krim verbindet da gab
es einen Anschlag drauf das ist die Krim
gehört seit
2014 völkerrechtlich rechtswidrig und
illegal nach russischer les Art zu
Russland nach völkerrechtlicher Lesart
aber zur Ukraine um diesen Umschlag gibt
es jetzt und sie meinen wahrscheinlich
auch es gab ja auch
unaufgeklärte Vorkommnisse auf
russischem Boden Explosionen
infektionsdepots ich glaube das meinte
das ist gab ja auch mindestens zwei
Angriffe auf strategische Flugplätze wo
Atombomber russischer Atombombe stehen
und zwar von ukrainischer Seite aber
kein Atomwaffen also wir müssen aber
genau unterscheiden wollen
auch die Infrastruktur des Angreifers
angreifen
so nicht meint sondern er meinte was ist
denn die Strategie wenn wir die Ukraine
weiterhin massenhaft mit mit zum
Beispiel auch Kampfpanzern ausstatten
ich möchte an der Stelle gerne einen
aktuellen ARD Deutschlandtrend
Einspielen der ist im Morgenmagazin am
Freitag also vorgestern gezeigt worden
und wir haben folgende Frage gestellt
sollte Deutschland schwere Kampfpanzer
wie den Leopard an die Ukraine liefern
46% sind dafür 43 % sind dagegen also
durchaus gespalten interessant wird es
aber wenn wir jetzt nach West und Ost
unterteilen denn da gibt es deutliche
Unterschiede ich dachte diese Zahlen
könnten wir auch noch zeigen im Westen
sind 50 % dafür 38 dagegen im Osten sind
32 % dafür 59% der gegen also die
Mehrheiten im Westen jeder zweite dafür
im Osten eine klare Mehrheit dagegen
übrigens grundsätzlich größere Skepsis
bei den jüngeren Menschen in Deutschland
und mehr Zustimmung für Waffenlieferung
bei den älteren das heißt wir haben
tatsächlich ein unklares gespaltenes
Meinungsbild in Deutschland und dazu
darauf bezieht sich auch Marco löwert
auf Youtube je nach Umfrage gibt es
keine eindeutige Mehrheit warum sollten
wir denn dann liefern her Cornelius ich
glaube bei uns haben wir da eben schon
geschildert in welcher militärischen
Lage sich die Ukraine befindet und die
Prognosen aller wirklich vernünftigen
Menschen die sich damit befassen von
der Dienste der der militäranalysten
sagen voraus dass dieses Frühjahr
möglicherweise eine militärische
Entscheidung bringt weil mit einem mit
einer zweiten Angriffswelle zu rechnen
ist und zwar nicht nur in einem Ort
nämlich im Don Bass und dann eventuell
auch von Belarus von Norden her und die
militärische Analyse und jetzt komme ich
zu den Leopards warum sie wichtig sind
die militärische Analyse sagt wenn es
gelingt der Ukraine diesen Zangen
Angriff sofort zu kommen und gerade im
Don Bass im Süden wo Russland sich sehr
sehr fest
klickrahmen hat es tut mir leid dass das
jetzt so militärisch wird und so
technisch quasi aber das ist im Moment
eben mal der Kern der Analyse dass man
dort von etwa der saporizer bei einer
Karte hätten wird man sehen das ist etwa
in der Mitte des Landes Richtung
Schwarzes Meer runterstößt und quasi
dann tatsächlich eine Ausgangslage hat
wie wir sie vor einem Jahr hatten dann
wäre dieser Punkt erreicht über den sie
gesprochen haben bis übrigens geht der
Krieg und ich glaube auch das ist kein
Geheimnis dass alle Analysten in den USA
bei der NATO selbst in der Ukraine sagen
wenn man diesen Status Quote hat also
den Tag des 23 Februar 22 dann ist der
Punkt für Verhandlungen vielleicht da
wenn die andere Seite behandeln möchte
auch das ist ein wichtiges Argument das
heißt immer warum verhandelt keiner ja
weil Puten nicht verhandeln will und um
diesen lässt Ersatz um diesen Angriff
dieses Situation zu erzielen müssen sie
mit sehr schweren gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
Gefährten dort ist sehr schnell kommen
und dass sie nun mal europarts und was
man nicht vergessen darf an dieser
Stelle genau vor einem Jahr hatten wir
eine ähnliche Debatte soll man die
Ukraine unterstützen auch militärisch
das war vor dem Krieg und man muss eines
mal ganz klar sagen wenn die Amerikaner
damals so gehandelt hätten wie Olaf
Scholz dann würden in Kiew heute
russische Militärparaden abgehalten
plodomir selensky und Vitali Klitschko
werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr am
Leben
tausende Menschen gefoltert noch mehr
Menschen gefoltert als ohnehin schon und
ich kann Ihnen sagen ich werde diese
Stunden als Reporter dort in Kiew in den
ersten Tagen nie vergessen meine
ukrainischen Freunde dachten sie werden
jeden Moment erschossen die Stadt wird
eingekreist eingekesselt das ist das
Gefühl mit dem dort jeden Morgen die
Menschen aufgewacht sind und wenn man
jetzt sagt wir müssen wieder warten wir
müssen prüfen dann muss man sagen wir
riskieren wieder genau das was vor einem
Jahr passiert ist und viele Menschen
mögen das schon vergessen haben aber es
war sehr sehr knapp wenn die Russen zum
Beispiel in dem Flughafen hostome diesen
eingenommen hätten ja dann wäre es sehr
wahrscheinlich gewesen dass Kiew
gefallen wäre und auch damals gab es
Militärberater die gesagt haben es
dauert nur noch Tage nur noch Stunden
und wir stehen genau wieder vor dieser
Lage möchte gerne auf die Frage der
Strategie noch mal zurückkommen sie
haben jetzt gerade ein Szenario
beschrieben der Status quo ante also
quasi der 23 Februar
ein Tag bevor die russische Armee in der
Ukraine einmarschiert ist das haben sie
jetzt gerade beschrieben als ein
Szenario in dem man dann verhandeln
könnte mit Russland habe ich Sie richtig
verstanden in Russland bereit ist wenn
wenn Russland dann bereit wäre zu
handeln aber jedenfalls das Ziel aus
ihrer Sicht muss jetzt erstmal sein dass
rückgängig zu machen was seit dem 24
Februar passiert ist zu der Frage Moskau
Ja oder Nein im
exklusiven Interview was der ukrainische
Präsidentin am
Donnerstag der ARD gegeben hat hat er
noch mal explizit gesagt damit wollen
wir nicht nach Russland einmarschieren
sondern wir wollen uns verteidigen das
ist jedenfalls die offizielle
ukrainische Position aber gleichzeitig
sagt help silenski auch wir wollen am
Ende den Donbass und die Krim zurück die
seit 2014 völkerrechtswidrig besetzt
worden sind das heißt ich will nur mal
sagen wo bis wohin wollen wir denn die
Ukraine unterstützen was ist das
strategische Ziel sie haben gesagt
24.02 Status Quote was aber wenn die
Ukraine noch mehr möchte aus ihrer Sicht
völlig gerechtfertigt weil auch da ist
sie ja überfallen worden aber wie
schätzen Sie das ein ich bin es wirklich
für mich die strategische Frage die wir
hier zusammen ich finde das wahnsinnig
ich weiß nicht ob das so klar ist ich
weiß auch nicht ob die Amerikaner sich
so klar positioniert haben also wenn ich
mir den us-generalstoffchef anhöre ja
und zwar seit letzten November wo er ja
gesagt hat eigentlich ist dieser Krieg
äh nicht mit militärischen Mitteln zu
lösen er hat sich ja dann noch
präzisiert und er hat gesagt wir haben
eine wie sie sehr gut beschrieben haben
ja vielleicht auch noch mal besser
beschreiben könnten ist es ja eine
kilometerlange Front und das ist
eigentlich ein Stellungskrieg wenn wir
Ihnen im Zweiten Weltkrieg wenn ich
sogar im Ersten Weltkrieg über 2000 km
und der hat ganz klar gesagt wir müssen
sozusagen die Ukraine auch langfristig
das ist zum Beispiel auch etwas was mit
in Deutschland diskutieren muss wir
haben keine Kultur darüber zu
diskutieren dass es ein lang anhaltender
Krieg der sehr kostspielig ist das hat
mir ja gesagt und er hat auch gesagt wir
müssen die Ukraine in eine Situation
bringen ja wo sie dann verhandeln kann
die Verhandlungsposition entscheidet
sich auf dem Schlachtfeld und ich glaube
nicht dass die Amerikaner gesagt haben
dass inkludiert die Krim ja und ich
glaube auch nicht dass sie gesagt haben
inkludiert unbedingt den Donnerstag
sondern das wird sich entscheiden das
wird sich dann im Frühjahr irgendwie
entscheiden und wer das entscheide
werden die Amerikaner sein weil
diejenigen sind die das meiste da rein
ähm einfach investieren und ich glaube
wir können nur froh sein dass die noch
Teil sozusagen das auch irgendwie tun
weil wenn die Plötz ein bisschen
feststellen dass Ihr Interesse woanders
liegt und das kann ja auch passieren
wenn nämlich im Indopazifik wo ihr
eigentliches Interesse ist irgendwas los
ist dann wird das sehr schwierig ich
gebe Ihnen sofort das Wort Herr Bonze
gebe Ihnen aber gerne eine Frage eines
Twitter Users mit warum wird eigentlich
gar nichts im diplomatischen Bereich
getan um Verhandlungen zu erreichen
warum wird kein Druck von den Medien und
der Politik ausgeübt um die Diplomatie
in den Vordergrund zu stellen es wird
immer nur massiv Druck bei
Waffenlieferungen gemacht warum ja die
Frage ist durchaus berechtigt die stelle
ich mir nämlich auch also ich bin seit
20 Jahren in Brüssel habe erlebt wie die
Europäer
betont haben wir sind ein
Friedensbündnis wir sind auf Frieden aus
wir setzen auf Diplomatie wir haben die
softpower und die hardpower haben wir
nicht die haben auch heute übrigens noch
nicht längst nicht ausreichend und seit
dem 24 Februar letzten Jahres tauchen
die Worte Frieden und Diplomatie und
softbauer in Brüssel nicht mehr auf und
wenn Sie nachfragen wenn Sie nachfragen
z.B beim Auswärtigen Dienst bei im Außen
beauftragten Borell sagt er der Krieg
wird auf dem Schlachtfeld entschieden
also erwähnt aber er erwähnt noch nicht
mehr mehr die Option Verhandlungen
danach oder wie auch immer und das ist
für mich eine ganz große Lücke ein ganz
großes Defizit in Brüssel aber auch in
Berlin denn auch der Kanzler sagt ja
nicht was ist das Ziel er sagt immer nur
wir müssen verhindern dass die Ukraine
verliert wie gesagt in Brüssel heißt es
schon unser Ziel ist dass die Ukraine
gewinnen dass sie siegt aber was ist
dieser Sieg das wird halt nicht
definiert daher kommt er eben diese
semantische Unschärfe und auch die
strategische Unsicherheit die Amerikaner
sagen etwas anderes als die Polen und es
gibt durchaus verschiedene Fraktionen
selbst innerhalb der EU ist man sich da
nicht eigentlich Frankreich sagt ja
sogar wir müssen auch in Russland
Sicherheitsgarantien geben für die Zeit
nach dem Krieg so lange das unklar ist
würde ich an holzstelle auch keine
Panzer liefern liefert keine Panzer in
einem Kriegsgebiet wenn man nicht weiß
was die Strategie ist was der Plan ist
umgekehrt wird aber auch ein Schulter
raus Scholz hat im Prinzip jetzt die
Möglichkeit diese Fragen zu klären ich
hoffe dass wir diese Chance ergreift
dass hinter den Kulissen bereits
Gespräche laufen das wäre die einzige
positive Aspekt die sich durch dieser
Diskussion abgewinnen kann ansonsten
fürchte ich dass diese Debatte um Leo 2
letzten Endes als Türöffner dient und
zwar dazu dass im Grunde genommen das
gesamte Arsenal der Bundeswehr aber auch
andere Armeen sozusagen freigegeben wird
die Ukraine sagt hallo wir brauchen
dieses Jahr fast wörtlich so gesagt her
damit und das kann es ja nicht sein ich
meine es kann ja nicht sein dass ich
alliierte wie Deutschland aber auch ein
ganzes Bündnis komplett in den Dienst
der Ukraine stellen ohne diese
strategischen Fragen zu klären das ist
für mich ein ganz großes Manko und da
kommen wir auch
gefährliche Frage können sie nicht
klären und es wäre fatal wenn sie jetzt
sagen würden was ist das Ziel das also
das würden nicht Amerikaner nie tun das
ist sie müssen das im Nebel lassen sie
müssen irgendwann feststellen wann ist
der Punkt erreicht wer bestimmt diesen
Punkt das ist strategisches Denken und
darin gibt es eben keine Kultur oder nur
wenig Kultur solche Sachen eigentlich zu
denken und nochmal diese
leoparddebatte ich finde ja es ist eine
Scheindebatte das ist genauso eine
ähnliche Debatte die von viel
Irrationalität auch gesteuert ist sie
erinnert mich sehr an die Debatte die
wir hatten über die bewaffneten Drohnen
da haben wir zehn Jahre lang darüber
diskutiert ob man Drohnen bewaffnen darf
oder nicht die Argumente waren am Anfang
der zehn Jahre bereits ausgetauscht noch
mal der Leopard ist ein Teil in einem
Verbund von Waffen was effektiv wirkt ja
alleine genommen bringt er gar nichts
und das ist das was man sich überlegen
muss das ist das was man sich taktisch
nicht strategisch sondern taktisch
überlegen muss wie kriege ich das hin in
Europa dass ich die Ukraine in die Lage
versetzen an dieser Front ja mit diesen
einzelnen Kompanien zu wirken und das
kann die Bundesrepublik gar nicht
alleine lassen
das sehe ich nicht oder wenn dann wird
es nicht kommuniziert wir müssen über
die Taktik reden aber auch wenn die
Strategie und was sie sagen natürlich
kann das nur Verbund funktionieren das
ist ja völlig klar das liegt ja auf der
Hand nur Herr Melnik der ehemalige
Botschafter der Ukraine sagt schon es
geht darum dass es keine roten Linien
mehr gibt in Deutschland er sagt und das
ist ein Zitat aus einem Interview dass
er gegeben weil wir brauchen nicht nur
Kampfpanzer wir brauchen Kampfjets wir
brauchen keksschiffe wir brauchen
Artillerie
da ist doch alles doch
halten das ist so lange bis das geklärt
hat schon als ukrainischer Botschafter
in Deutschland und jetzt als Vize
Außenminister darf solche Sachen fordern
die Frage ist ja wie verhält sich
Deutschland wie verhalten sich die
europäischen Partner dazu
Cornelius wir haben jetzt hier schon die
große Strategie können wir
wahrscheinlich hier am Tisch heute nicht
festlegen deshalb ein plädoy dafür
erstmal einen Schritt weiter zu kommen
warum zögert der Kanzler was meinen Sie
sich trotzdem ein Wort zu dem großen
wortstrategießen immer so ist ein ein
tarnbegriff um irgendwas mysteriöses zu
verschleiern was wir angeblich ist das
ist nicht richtig das große Ziel ist als
dass dieser Krieg endet keiner der heute
Waffen liefert möchte krieg ja also ist
die suggerieren dass alle die für diese
leopardlieferung sind sozusagen
kriegslüstern sind das ist nicht richtig
es geht darum die Ukraine zu befähigen
durch hinreichende abschreckungskraft
Russland von weiteren Angriffen
abzuhalten beziehungsweise sieht so weit
in einem militärische Bredouille zu
bringen das selbst in Moskau die
Einsicht wächst wir müssen verhandeln
dann wird verhandelt und dann
diskutieren über Strategie selbst wenn
die Krim nicht erobern würde oder das
Dornbach die die Region selbst dann
würde das nicht automatisch Russland
zufallen völkerrechtlich wäre das eine
Katastrophe wenn wir in Europa
Territorien verschieben nur weil einer
mir Panzer rüberfährt das wäre auch für
uns hier ein ganz verheerende Signal das
heißt es geht darum diesen Krieg zu
beenden das Töten zu werden und die
Frage ist an welche Linie endet das all
das hat Herr Mille gesagt übrigens sehr
oft zitiert wird und falsch zitiert wird
Milli hat nie gesagt der Krieg ist nicht
zu gewinnen der hat höchstens gesagt der
Krieg ist militärisch zu verlieren
nämlich dann wenn man sich nicht genug
wehren kann so und jetzt zur Frage warum
bewegt sich der Kanzler nicht riesige
Frage am liebsten hätte ich ihn hier und
würde ihnen das jetzt fragen er schweigt
und das ist die größte Katastrophe der
deutschen Außenpolitik momentan weil er
sich nicht erklärt ich gebe Ihnen drei
Motive und wahrscheinlich stimmen sie
alle aber er sagt sie nicht das erste
ist natürlich gibt es sonst sie haben es
vorher erwähnt einer eine große
historische Last auf Deutschland und die
Sorge dass irgendwann ein Leopard vor
einem russischen Panzer steht und die
sich beschießen und das möchte man
eigentlich nicht zweitens gibt es ein
ganz banales innenpolitisches Motiv wir
haben die Zahlen gerade gesehen der
Kanzler guckt seine Mehrheiten sind der
guckt wie ihm die Unterstützung davon
läuft oder nicht davon läuft also eine
sehr sehr schwierige Entscheidung ich
möchte es nicht bewerten aber ich kann
Anerkennung Objektiv dass jemand der Amt
ist darauf achten muss und drittens gibt
es natürlich dann die Frage ist
Deutschland exponiert also würde
Deutschland sich mit dieser
leopard-entscheidung so weit
singularisieren herausheben aus der
Gruppe der Verbündeten dass wir selbst
zum Ziel werden politisch dafür durch
Russland das Putin sagt ihr deutschen
ihr seid's und er sät damit sweet Tracht
und diese Gefahr möchte stolz vorbeugen
das sehe ich auch ein aber ich glaube im
Moment macht er genau das Gegenteil er
singularisiert sich durch nicht
Teilnahme und richte damit anderen
Schaden an also der Leopard ist für
seine militärische Notwendigkeit
inzwischen wirklich unbestritten ich
glaube auch der Ukraine zu unterstellen
dass sie ihn für offensive Zwecke jetzt
Missbrauch das ist offensiv ich meine
die verteidigen ihr Land ich habe keine
Interesse nach Russland offen
wenn sie irgendwo im Leben bleibt und
nicht dass er kein Interesse und man
muss sich ja einmal anschauen wo wir
angekommen sind in dieser Debatte
nämlich dort das Polen damit droht die
Leopard ohne deutsches go sozusagen in
die Ukraine zu schicken also Deutschland
hat sich so weit in Europa isoliert und
man darf ja auch eine Sache nicht
vergessen der französische Präsident
macron der am Anfang immer als derjenige
galt der wahnsinnig auf Russland eingeht
immer mit Putin telefoniert er ist es
der gesagt hat ja wir müssen Kampfpanzer
schicken schon viel länger
Großbritannien hat Challenger geschickt
und hat sozusagen dafür gesorgt dass das
ja schon passiert ich verstehe in dieser
Debatte eine Sache nicht ähm selenski
sagt wir brauchen dies wir brauchen das
jetzt was ist sozusagen aus Scholz Sicht
der Unterschied zwischen ähm Gebhardt
zwischen anderen Systemen die geliefert
wurden und jetzt dem Leopard 2 ich sehe
sozusagen keine äh qualitative in dem
Sinne dass das jetzt die sich Putins auf
Deutschland verändern sollte und ähm sie
haben es angesprochen glaube das größte
Problem auch wenn man sich diese Umfrage
anschaut ist doch das scheut sich wieder
in die eine noch in die andere Richtung
erklärt ich glaube das momentan beide
Seiten in Deutschland also diejenigen
die dafür sind und diejenigen die
dagegen sind nicht verstehen warum der
Kanzler handelt wieder handelt sie
gleich ich möchte noch eine kurze
Nachfrage an Sie stellen Herr Melnik
wurde gerade zitiert der sagt also der
Vize-Außenminister der Ukraine es darf
keine roten Linien mehr geben ein Nutzer
fragt was wäre denn möglicherweise eine
rote Linie heronsheimer Kampfflugzeuge
Drohnen Raketen
Atombomben gut das hat Deutschland jetzt
nicht aber nein also jetzt mal ganz
ernsthaft ich nehme ja aus der Debatte
mit der Kampfpanzer Leopard ist aus
ihrer Sicht jetzt alleine gar kein Game
changer wie man neudeutsch so schön sagt
sondern ist in einer Historie von
verschiedenen Unterstützung zu
betrachten wie weit muss es aus ihrer
Sicht noch gehen also ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass einfach die Zahl also die
reine Masse an Kampfpanzern und an
Artillerie zunimmt in Russland ist der
klaren Vorteil wenn sie dort an der
Front unterwegs sind sagen in die
ukrainischen Soldaten wir können uns
häufig gar nicht wehren bzw nicht
zurückschießen weil wir auch nicht
genügend Munition oder nicht genügend
Artillerie eben dort haben also das ist
das wichtige wenn wir über rote Linien
sprechen glaube ich
muss man ganz klar sagen die rote Linie
ist keine Beteiligung von Nato-Soldaten
von deutschen Soldaten an diesem
Kriegsgeschehen was jetzt das reine
Material angeht da würde ich immer sagen
es hängt von der Lage vor Ort also keine
Soldaten auf ukrainischem Gebiet meinen
sie genau weil zum Beispiel Ausbildung
würde ja außerhalb der Tüte empfohlen
sie wollten gerade auf den Wohnzimmer
reden ja also ich wollte eigentlich auf
hanselensky eingehen er hat auch schon
sehr viel gesagt vor zwei Wochen hat er
gejubelt als der Marder freigegeben
wurde und gesagt das ist ein Durchbruch
jetzt plötzlich sagt er ohne den Leo
können wir nicht leben also da muss man
doch sehr vorsichtig sein er hat auch
schon behauptet dass die Raketen die in
Polen eingeschlagen sind dass das
russische gewesen sein und heute nicht
davon ab und die Fazit hat daraufhin
geschrieben
Tipps geben möchte die NATO mehr oder
weniger in den Krieg ziehen also da muss
man auch vorsichtig sein was zu lensky
sagt für meine Begriffe läuft da im
Moment wirklich eine massive Kampagne
die sich zum größten Teil eben auch
gegen Deutschland richtet und das ist
für mich nicht nachvollziehbar das macht
mich ebenso sprachlos und ich glaube
auch viele zuhören Zuhörer und viele
Bürger in Deutschland warum konzentriert
sich diese ganzen
darf ich das mal kurz ausführen auf
Deutschland die USA schicken keinen sie
sagen zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt
natürlich
verlieren also der schwere Kampfpanzer
der USA
genau unter anderem auch aus
logistischen Gründen weil sie ja über
den Atlantik sagen sie ist so der Abrams
ist natürlich schon massiv an der
Ostflanke der Natur das ist ja bekannt
er wird ähm er wird versteckt über
Seeland bei Belgien das wird in den
belgischen Medien groß berichtet mir
mein dass er nicht an der Ostgrenze es
gibt ein paar Millionen in Polen
Entschuldigung
die Amerikaner liefern keine eher Bünz
die Franzosen die von bisher keinen
lecler die Briten liefern ein paar
Challenger aber das wird nicht den
Unterschied machen und die Ukraine sagen
wir brauchen mindestens 300 Kampfpanzer
und das ist überhaupt
erreichen gerade weil man noch die
Sorgen ernst nehmen muss und man muss
doch irgendwie natürlich auch eine
Unterstützung übrigens auch ein bisschen
empathie ist ja vielleicht auch nicht
verkehrt in dieser ganzen Debatte also
wenn ich mir diese Bilder angucke das
finde ich immer so schwierig bei solchen
militärischen Diskussionen dass man auch
einfach ein bisschen Empathie vielleicht
mitbringen muss und Verständnis dafür
also mir geht es zumindest so wenn ich
darüber spreche aber die Ukraine das ist
doch völlig logisch wenn ich mir
vorstelle ich stehe mit dem Rücken zur
Wand dann fordere ich alles und zwar
massiv von meinen angeblichen Partnern
die sich ja dauernd hinstellen und sagen
wir geben euch alles damit Ihr diesen
Krieg nicht verliert eine andere Sache
ist doch dass ich als Partner in die
Vorhand komme und sage okay was können
wir realistischerweise bieten und was
macht vor allen Dingen auch Sinn und das
ist etwas was ich in der deutschen
Diskussion auch in der deutschen Politik
absolut vermisse ja dass man sich
hinstellt und sagt okay lasst uns das
Organisieren das im übrigen erwarten
auch nicht die Franzosen ja die Polen
wollen das gar nicht den kommt es jetzt
innenpolitisch zu passt aber eigentlich
ist die Forderung der Amerikaner ganz
klar macht endlich eure Hausaufgaben
macht eure Hausaufgaben und löst das in
Europa und das muss natürlich unter
deutscher Führung passieren also wenn
ich noch mal die Dresden wenn ich noch
mal nicht die Dresdner sondern die
Aachen Rede von Scholz mir letzten
August wir möchten Ost-West Süd und Nord
zusammenführen ja was heißt denn das was
heißt das jetzt konkret in der Situation
dass ich mich zum Beispiel hinsetze und
ich glaube das ist Pistole es hat es auf
dem Zettel und sage okay wer hat wie
viele Panzer welche Modelle und dafür
gibt's Fachleute die das machen können
und dann eine klare Aussage zu treffen
da muss ich mich doch nicht treiben
lassen von der Ukraine diese
Führungsrolle die sie da gerade
beschreiben und sie haben es ja auch
angesprochen also Präsident macron der
immerhin engen Kontakt zu Vladimir Putin
versucht hat zu halten ist jetzt
letztendlich mich davon auch ziemlich
ernüchtert glauben Sie denn dass heute
rund um 60 Jahre elysee-vertrag da
treffen sich ja die Deutschen und
Franzosen zusammen auch Olaf Scholz und
Emmanuel macron das ist da durch ein
Impuls geben könnte der diese
europäische wir müssen das Problem lösen
in Anführungszeichen vielleicht wieder
ein bisschen Energie verschafft und
Kraftschub ich hoffe es dass zumindest
hinter den Kulissen da etwas passiert
dass es nämlich in diese Richtung geht
denn eins wird in Deutschland sehr
häufig vergessen es geht da wirklich um
Tage es geht um Stunden es geht um Tage
das etwas passiert das bestimmte Fronten
gestärkt werden können auf Seiten der
Ukraine ich persönlich glaube nicht dass
der Kanzler
sich noch mal wendet also schnell ich
glaube das ist irgendwann dazu kommen
wird aber dass er in seiner Sturheit so
weitermachen wird dass ihm das auch
völlig egal ist was wir hier am Tisch
sagen oder Medien schreiben oder
irgendjemand ihm sagen ich glaube auch
dass in seinem Umfeld er ist durchaus
Leute es gibt die für Panzerlieferungen
sind das ist auch das was ich aus der
SPD höre die sagen wir wollen das
Kampfpanzer geliefert werden aber wir
haben ihn im letzten Jahr erlebt er
lässt sich da nicht treiben ja wenn
Wochen und Monate lang geschrieben wird
der Kanzler soll endlich nach hier
fahren dann macht er es erst recht nicht
und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl
dass es jetzt auch der Fall
was meinen sie macht das Pistorius
genauso oder wird er sich da vielleicht
anders verhalten und sich ein etwas von
Scholz emanzipieren da habe ich meine
Zweifel dass er sich wirklich von Scholz
emanzipieren kann als Person sicherlich
als Politiker auch aber inhaltlich liegt
natürlich die Richtlinie Kompetenz beim
Kanzler und die hatte ja offenbar auch
schon den letzten Tagen ausgeübt und man
hört ja das Pistorius weitergehen wollte
bei dieser Kanzler Frage als der Kanzler
ich frage mich allerdings auch wollen
denn die Deutschen wirklich eine
Führungsrolle in einem Krieg gegen
Russland das ist ja letzten Endes der
Kern der Sache wenn sie sich umhören das
ist ja schon längst zu einem
Stellvertreter Krieg geworden es geht ja
längst nicht wenn du um die Ukraine
sondern es wird vorstellt auch aus der
Ukraine übrigens vom
Verteidigungsminister der hat neulich
gesagt vor zehn Tagen wir sind sozusagen
de facto schon Teil der NATO wir kämpfen
sozusagen für die NATO und die Russen
sagen Jesus ein Stellvertreterkrieg
Russland gegen die NATO soll Deutschland
in diesem Konflikt wenn man ihn so
definiert
russische
Propaganda ist das ähm die NATO geht wir
werden das mit dem formuliert mit dem
Stellvertreter krieg hier nicht mehr
fertig bringen in dieser Sendung
jedenfalls denn hier geht's jetzt im
ersten weiter mit dem europamagazin
unter anderem auch zum elise-vertrag und
den 60 Jahren deutsch-französischer
Freundschaft aber wenn sie weiter
debattieren wollen und vor allem sich
einschalten wollen auf Phoenix und WDR 5
Presseclub nachgefragt vielen Dank schon
mal bisschen für ihr Interesse machen
sie es gut bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder mit Presseclub
nachgefragt auf Phoenix WDR 5 und
natürlich auch in den sozialen Medien wo
wir gestreamt werden wir haben hier
gerade schon engagiert debattiert und
können das jetzt hier mit Fragen unserer
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer fortsetzen und ich möchte als
erstes gerne zu Jutta wird nach München
guten Tag und ihre Frage bitte
hallo bin ich in der Sendung ja sie sind
da hallo Frau Wirth grüß Gott an die
Runde mir kommt es darauf an dass die
Medien fast unisono auch in diesem
Presseclub drei zu eins praktisch
diese Lieferung von Leopard Panzern wie
ein Fetisch vor sich her tragen für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine das ist das
eine was ich bemängele dass da geradezu
eine Kampagne gefahren wird und jeder
der dreimal nachdenkt als Zauberer
hingestellt wird dies dreimal nachdenken
unterstütze ich wenn man wirklich
bedenkt dass die Deutschen jetzt
plötzlich lernen sollen es gibt auch
gute kriege
wie diesen Ukraine Krieg obwohl gerade
wir als Volk ja nun Europa mit
millionenfachen Tod überzogen haben und
das darf man doch bitteschön immer noch
im Hinterkopf be
halten dieses
tierisch fast
Fördern von diesem von dieser
leopardlieferung obwohl wenn man mal
fachlich auch in der Presse liest dass
das hier unterschiedliche Modelle gibt
und die Ukraine
darauf noch nicht ausgebildet sind und
wie gesagt die Dame das auch gesagt hat
dass das der Leopard alleine nur im
Verbund nützlich ist und wenn man sich
dann anhört dass wir demnächst auch
Kampfflugzeuge und Kriegsschiffe liefern
sollen da ist das einfach grenzenlos was
der propagiert wird Frau wird genau also
Sie haben gerade ihren ihren Punkt
gemacht sie haben ähnlich wie Herr bonse
auch davon gesprochen dass es eine Art
Kampagne im Moment gibt jedenfalls sehr
viel in Medien und Politik sehr viel
über diese Kampfpanzer gesprochen wird
sie haben sich für nachdenken
ausgesprochen
Kampfflugzeuge haben wir übrigens in
dieser Runde hier noch nicht zugesagt
muss man jetzt der Vollständigkeit
halber mal klarstellen und ähm ich gebe
das mal an Sie haben ja sich auch darauf
bezogen drei zu eins hier in der Runde
nehmen Sie das vielleicht der Cornelius
nehmen Sie das im Moment auch sogar die
Frau wird dass da sehr stark Druck
erzeugt wird und in diese Richtung der
es ist ein Vorwurf der immer wieder
kommt klar erreicht uns auch wir
bekommen sehr viele Briefe
es kam von einem der kommandierenden
Generäle in diesen Land auch das ganz
schreckliche Wort der Gleichschaltung
der Medien hin und da muss ich leider
wirklich mit aller mit aller
Entschiedenheit widersprechen es ist
auch nicht so dass wir nicht nachdenken
auch drei oder viermal wenn sie sich
wirklich mit Experten auseinandersetzen
und wir sprechen hier alle mit den
Leuten ist ja nicht so dass wir hier
alle panzerkommandeure wären oder oder
aber irgendwie beziehen unser Wissen
auch aus sehr sehr vielen Recherchen und
intensiven Gesprächen werden sie ein
Stimmungsbild erhalten bei den Experten
das ungefähr dem hier entspricht und
insofern ich verstehe Ihre ihren harder
ich verstehe Ihre Zweifel das was ihm
ihm nagt gerade historische Argument das
teilen wir alles wenn ich teile das
komplett aber wir sind wir erleben das
ein verdammt überfallen wurde und dieses
Land möchte sich wehren dieser Krieg
soll beendet werden und es gibt eine
sehr einhellige Meinung dass dieser
Krieg nur endet wenn er militärisch
nicht gewonnen werden kann in dem Moment
wo man der Ukraine die Hilfe entzieht
wird es diesen Krieg verlieren und dann
ist als nächstes Moldau dran und das
übernächst ist das Baltikum und Europa
zerfällt und das gilt es zu verhindern
und deswegen glaube ich ist das hier ein
sehr sehr
gerechtes Anliegen dass man diesen Land
hilft danke das war Frau wird aus
München und wir gehen weiter zu Frank
Knut in Berlin hallo und ihre Frage
bitte ja schönen guten Tag meine Frage
ist ganz einfach was ich nicht verstehe
wenn der Kanzler sagt sie müssen erstmal
sehen dass die Bundeswehr nicht lauter
Waffen abgeht warum er dann nicht
zulässt das andere starten wie Polen die
bereit sind Waffen zu liefern dass er
einfach die Erlaubnis gibt für die
deutschen machen die Bundeswehr oder wir
sind doch da überhaupt nicht von landet
in dem Sinne direkt beteiligt bei uns
wird ja abgezogen nichts das verstehe
ich nicht genau warum stimmt der Kanzler
es gibt diese diese den
Genehmigungsvorbehalt wenn deutsche
Waffen weitergeliefert werden von den
Vertragspartnern in diesem Fall von
Polen in die Ukraine muss Deutschland
zustimmen warum genehmigt der Kanzler
das nicht Frau bringt naja es ist doch
ganz klar dass genau das Argument wir
sind dann Kriegspartei weil jeder weiß
natürlich dass es deutsche Panzer sind
und das Deutschland dem zustimmen muss
und das ist ja gleichzusetzen wie als
würde Deutschland liefern also da müssen
wir uns doch nichts vormachen ja also
und wenn ich dem nicht zustimme sage ich
damit ich will den Daumen drauf haben
und ich will das nicht machen weil der
Leopard vielleicht ein polnisches
Hoheitszeichen drauf hat aber trotzdem
völlig klar ist es ist ein Panzer aus
deutscher Produktion und die
Bundesrepublik muss dem zustimmen also
das finde ich eigentlich ein ganz
logisches Argument und wenn man diese
Argumentation folgt die und das wissen
Sie wahrscheinlich besser
dann muss man dem natürlich auch mit
zögern segnen das ist doch ganz klar
danke wir gehen weiter nach Osterode am
Harz und zu Jürgen Nagel hallo ja
schönen guten morgen an die Runde ich
hätte mal eine grundsätzliche Bemerkung
ich war in den 70er Jahren als
Panzergrenadier in Augustdorf
stationiert und habe eine ganz schlechte
Zeit eigentlich eine an der Bundeswehr
erlebt weil ich irgendwie diese
Desorganisation damals schon nicht
gemacht hatte meine Frage an die Frau
Prinz ich bin also emotional auch sehr
stark betroffen durch diesen Krieg und
ich meine also dass die Ukraine auf
jeden Fall militärisch unterstützt
werden muss um entsprechend sich
gegenüberfall der Russen zu wehren warum
wird nicht schon rechtzeitig der Krieg
ist jetzt über ein Jahr oder fast ein
Jahr im Gange entsprechend organisiert
eine dass die Produktion von
Kampfpanzern in Deutschland hochgefahren
wird wenn wir nur 300 Punkte haben damit
kann sicherlich natürlich keine Wände in
dem Krieg erzeugt werden aber natürlich
sind da wirtschaftliche Gründe eine
Rolle aber im Grunde muss dieser Krieg
erstmal beendet werden oder muss massiv
entsprechend die Industrie in
Deutschland entsprechend organisiert
werden dass die die Rüstungsproduktion
hochfahren obwohl ich vom emotionale und
so weiter vollkommen dagegen bin also
Herr Nagel ihre Frage ist einerseits
warum wurde das noch nicht hochgefahren
bzw sie verweisen darauf wie lange das
eigentlich dauert jetzt diese Waffen
über die wir diskutieren tatsächlich
auch herzustellen oder entstand zu
setzen Frau bringt sie sind direkt
angesprochen worden ja gerne also müssen
wir wahrscheinlich noch mal eine extra
oder drei Sendungen machen warum die
Bundeswehr in dem Zustand ist wie sie
ist also tatsache ist ja dass sie in
einen Zustand ist und das hat nun da
zitiere ich jetzt mal den den Heeres
Inspektor iPhone meist der schon vor
einem Jahr gesagt hat im Grunde genommen
sind wir blank also wenn man blank ist
kann man nicht viel abgeben so jetzt
kann man sich fragen warum ist das nicht
ähm gelöst worden also die Industrie hat
sich ja hingestellt muss man auch immer
aufpassen dass man da nicht auf den
Argumenten ausrutscht also crossmacher
Wegner und drei Meter haben gesagt ist
ja gar kein Problem wir machen unsere
Garagen aus und stellen euch die Dinger
gleich hin das ist natürlich nicht der
Fall aber wenn man sich die
Argumentation des Kanzlers anguckt und
der Regierung dann ist ja völlig klar
dass damit gezögert worden ist natürlich
hätte man schon viel früher das machen
können und die Marder die man jetzt hat
die hat man ja geliefert den Geparden
auch übrigens die Patriots das sind ja
auch schon massive Waffen ist es ja
nicht nichts das muss man sich
vielleicht auch immer noch mal klar
machen das klingt immer so nüchtern und
so brutal aber deutschland ist der
zweitgrößte Geber nach den Vereinigten
Staaten und der größte in Europa und das
bezieht sich nicht nur auf Waffen wenn
wir jetzt nicht nur auf die Waffen
konzentrieren sondern natürlich auch an
ziviler Unterstützung damit dieser Staat
weiter am Laufen bleibt damit Gehälter
übrigens bezahlt werden könnte man in
der ganzen Diskussion nicht vergessen
ich finde es immer so schade dass das
auch politisch nicht kommuniziert wird
aber natürlich muss man eine ähm und
Pistole hat es ja gesagt die Zeiten
wegen der fängt jetzt erst an also 100
Jahre dauern bis sozusagen die Bestände
wieder so aufgefüllt sind dass die
Bundeswehr nicht blank ist danke wir
versuchen ja möglichst viele Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer zu Wort kommen zu lassen
Sabine Hedel aus Essen hat uns angerufen
guten Tag ja guten Tag
auch in seiner zögerlichen Haltung und
für mich ist die Frage warum will der
eben unbedingt dass auch die USA
Kampfpanzer liefern unsere Vermutung ist
dass er die USA zu einer höheren
Sicherheitsgarantie zwingen will falls
es zu einem Gegenangriff Russlands auf
nato-gebiet kommt also kurz gesagt dass
sie dann also nun wirklich auch mit
Atomwaffen drohen ähm wenn es zu einem
gegen andere kommt und dann nicht sagen
das verhackstückelt ihr mal auf
europäischen Boden alleine
wollen Sie darauf antworten also da kann
man nur spekulieren ich glaube dass die
USA bislang nie den Eindruck erweckt
haben dass sie das nicht machen würden
wenn ein NATO statt angegriffen wurde
von daher sehe ich jetzt in der
Argumentation keinen Grund dass man die
USA in eine Richtung da noch pushen
müsste ich glaube es ist tatsächlich
seine Haltung so wie er immer
argumentiert hat in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten das sind die drei Gründe die
Stefan Cornelius angesprochen hatte
einerseits die Meinungsumfragen die
Putin Drohung und das ist das was ihn
treibt
wir gehen weiter zu Angela Beerbaum nach
Dinslaken hallo und ihre Frage an die
Runde bitte schön groß in die Runde es
geht darum warum wird eigentlich nicht
die Meinung des allgemeinen Volkes
berücksichtig es ist ja so dass die
Jugend zwischen 18 und 34 oder 35
teilweise gegen die Waffenlieferungen
sind ich bin kein Verfechter von Herrn
er ist nicht mein lieblingskanzler aber
ich bin froh dass wir in dieser
Situation jemanden haben der nach dem
alten Spruch regiert ich setze erstmal
ein Verstand ein und dann mein Mundwerk
nämlich bei vielen ist es ja so dass
zuerst immer die breite Masse schreit
die anderen laufen hinterher und keiner
vielleicht mal wirklich darüber
nachdenkt warum er das so macht
vielleicht hat er irgendwelche
Informationen wie wir nicht haben und
die nicht sofort auf dem Tablet steht
wie gesagt ich bin 70 Jahre und wie
gesagt ich bin auch dafür dass auch die
Allgemeinheit dabei bei der ganzen
Diskussion etwas zu sagen hat ja danke
Frau Beerbaum also auch sie machen sich
in dem Zusammenhang verständlicherweise
sorgen und begrüßen das Nachdenken des
Kanzlers hat er Informationen die wir
nicht haben Herr Kornelius nein das
glaube ich nicht sonst hätte sie
wahrscheinlich schon mitgeteilt wir
versuchen das ja auch zu erfahren und
wenn ich vielleicht ein bisschen werden
darf dafür wie bei uns politische
Prozesse laufen ähm weder entscheidet
der Kanzler ganz autark und alleine noch
entscheiden wir hier am Tisch Gott
bewahre der diskutieren nur das ist eine
Demokratie dass wir den Parlament
entschieden dass wir in allen Parteien
diskutiert also ich glaube Sie haben ja
auch gewählt vermutlich und sie sind
insofern repräsentiert in der Regierung
und der Kanzler hat am Ende die
Entscheidungshoheit er ist am Ende
derjenige der bei solchen enorm
strategischen Fragen das letzte Wort hat
und wir erleben einen dieser ganz
seltenen Momente in einer Demokratie wo
eine enorm wichtige Frage auch sehr sehr
kontrovers diskutiert werden erinnert
sich wie die Pandemie am Anfang
diskutiert wurde wer muss über jede
Kleinigkeit enorm erregt und auch erst
Wissen sammeln müssen genau das passiert
nun auch und ich finde das nicht
verwerflich das muss man auch aushalten
und deswegen müssen wir vorsichtig sein
zu sagen die haben nicht genug
nachgedacht oder die reagieren vor
schnell oder brechen vor das ist nicht
der Fall also ich verbinde mein gesamten
Berufstag darauf darüber nachzudenken
und sogar dem den Abend und die macht
manchmal weil es treibt mich auch um das
kann ich verstehen und ich glaube das
geht im Moment sehr sehr vielen so ähm
versuchen noch Tobias Vogel aus Berlin
zu hören hallo und was wollen Sie gerne
von der Runde wissen ja also
meine Frau ist Russland 25 Jahre
verheiratet und sie
richtet ja wieder ihr Spiegel durch die
russische Community in Berlin bzw vielen
Freundinnen in Russland die eben alle
ein fürchterlichen Kurs einnehmen in der
Richtung also solcher Bemerkungen wie
litauen hat keine Existenzberechtigung
die Ukraine die die schöne sollen sich
doch bitte nicht ziehen
diese Position die erfindert mich schon
insofern insofern bin ich auch ein
bisschen Insider aber auch viel mit
russischen Lobbyisten zu tun gehabt und
nicht orientiert wahnsinnig eins es ist
noch niemals seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
als Hitler ganz Europa überfallen hat
ein so klarer verbrecherischer
Angriffskrieg gestartet worden ja so
einseitig und so deutlich ist dass ein
eine Atom macht ein Land überfällt und
diese ganzen
Vorbehalte sozusagen die einflüchte die
so in meiner in sich zynisch der Stolz
das erste Angebot von Frau lambrechts
5000 Helme zu liefern dann die zweiten
verzögerungsargumente warum dieses und
jenes nicht geliefert wird um dann drei
Monate später wieder weiter zu liefern
ja Vogel wir sind fast schon am Ende der
Sendung haben sie noch eine konkrete
Frage ich habe ihre Position gut
verstanden was wäre ihre Frage noch an
die Runde meine Frage
bezogen auf den Herrn der sozusagen die
Position der nicht Leoparden
einnimmt wie welche welche Befürchtungen
bzw welche Erklärung oder Entschuldigung
hatte er denn das Verhältnis von von
Putin und Russland welche Erklärung gibt
es da bzw welche Ansätze würde es jedem
irgendwie mit diesen Menschen überhaupt
zu behandeln okay also sie wollen von
Herrn Bonze konkret wissen der sicher
etwas differenziert hier zu den
Panzerlieferungen geäußert hat was
sollte Ihrer Meinung nach jetzt
passieren in Anbetracht der russischen
Aggression wir sind leider fast am Ende
versteher und auch kein Russland
verstehe ich sag nur wenn Leopard 2
geliefert werden sollten dann muss das
in eine Strategie eingebunden sein und
die in auch natürlich auch ein
militärischen Verbund und die muss offen
gelegt werden und solange das nicht der
Fall ist habe ich da genau wie der
Kanzler massive Vorbehalte und ich
glaube damit stehe ich auch nicht
alleine
danke Herr Bonze damit stehen Sie nicht
alleine wir haben hier in dieser Runde
heute über die panzerfrage sehr
engagiert und differenziert diskutiert
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse an der
Sendung wir werden sicherlich noch
weitere Presseclubs zu dem Thema machen
ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Sonntag
danke